Hallo herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim love.
In ungewohnt schneller folge rattern hier die themen durch weil es einfach so interessant gibt einfach so viel.
Zu besprechen rundum die uns all umfassende und versenken korona krise
ach ja und irgendwie auch mal ganz befreiend sich ein wenig unterhalten zu können einfach um gedankenaustausch zu betreiben und vor allem auf die ganzen sachen mal zu schauen
die jetzt so abgehen und eine dieser situation ist natürlich ganz klar die situation in den schulen die alle
entweder direkt oder zumindest mittelbar betreffen auf die eine oder andere art und weise und dazu quatsch ich heute mit jörg ran mus mehr holz hallo johann.
Johann sag doch mal den hörerinnen und hörern kurz was du so treibst und warum du glaubst dass ich dich ausgewählt habe um darüber zu sprechen.
Der zweite teil ist der schwieriger ich bin ein diplompädagogin das muss man vielleicht den jüngeren erklären diplom war mal einen abschluss an deutschen universitäten ähm
für menschen die in diesem feld jetzt pädagogik nicht lehrer werden wollten das heißt ich habe das zwar mal mit der pädagogik kennengelernt da war vor allem mit hinblick auf die arbeit mit erwachsenen
ich hab ein schwerpunkt dabei der an all diesen schnittstellen zu digitalen medien liegt damit hat man dann keine vernünftige berufsbezeichnung oder sowas.
Wenn man keinen vernünftigen berufsziel hat man hat man sich berater auch dann weiß man aber nicht wer das ist also so zwischen den stühlen die lehrer sagen ich bin ja kein richtiger pädagoge die journalisten sagen ich bin kein richtiger journalist die wissenschaftler sagen
ich bin kein richtiger wissenschaftler irgendwo zwischen diesen stühlen.
Ja ich bin ja auch gar kein richtiger radio mensch von daher passt das wunderbar rein
aber du hast viel erfahrung mit dem ganzen
education system so weil du das schon seit längerer zeit betrachtest sowohl wie es sich an sich entwickelt wie es funktioniert und natürlich und das natürlich auch ein teil unserer diskussion heute
wie er sich vor allem der modernität zuwendet beziehungsweise das nicht tut,
und das natürlich jetzt ein aspekt der durch diesen stillstand unserer bewegung auch nochmal besonders in den fokus gerät
halten wir doch vielleicht erstmal so die situation fest wie sie sich jetzt gerade so abzeichnet
also wir haben muss man jetzt mal dazu sagen den sechsten april zwanzig zwanzig heute ist eigentlich der offizielle beginn der osterferien ich glaube so fast überall manche haben.
Fast überall genau und merkt man bloß nicht viel von weil die schulen haben jetzt schon seit drei wochen zu,
genau seit drei wochen also das ging dann auch in dem einen oder anderen bundesland etwas,
schneller oder eben später in berlin war es genau vor drei wochen da wurden dann die schüler noch mal ganz kurz in die schule gebeten wurde ihnen kurz gesagt so schule ist jetzt vorbei jetzt könnt ihr wieder nach hause fahren auch so ein bisschen merkwürdig der move,
so war es auf jeden fall und seitdem sind die schulen abgeschlossen und dort findet,
nur noch in ausnahmefällen irgendetwas statt und das ganze schulsystem,
versucht jetzt in irgendeiner form mit dieser situation klarzukommen mit unterschiedlichen erfolgen.
Was hast du denn so bisher gehört und gesehen wie das.
Funktioniert beziehungsweise in in welcher form überhaupt der schulbetrieb jetzt betroffen ist oder eben auch doch vielleicht versucht noch weiter zu leben.
Das ist ja eine situation das hört man in diesen tagen öfter oder man sagt es öfter wie man sie sich nicht hätte vorstellen können vorher,
wir sehen im moment ganz vieles was vorher als unvorstellbar galt es wird tatsächlich ganz viel gemacht was vorher nicht mal denkbar war es gibt ganz viel aufbruchstimmung bis hin zur euphorie und hype gerade in sachen was man mit digitalen medien machen kann.
Gleichzeitig glaube ich ganz viel elend und ganz viel zweifel ganz viel stress was man vielleicht nicht so sieht weil,
was man sieht ist das keine ahnung was in die sendung die jetzt nicht brennpunkt heißt.
Extra.
Was da gezeigt wird oder was man auf twitter sieht oder sowas das sind ja nur sachen die nach draußen getragen werden wie viele weil sie nicht verzweifelte lehrer wie für verzweifelte familien es gibt etcetera haben wir
fast gar keine ahnung ich vermute aber dass es mehr ist als wir uns so ausmalen und wir haben.
Kuddelmuddelig die situation in den schulen also alles was wir jetzt sagen kann in diesem gespräch muss man eigentlich sich bei jedem satz dazu denken das gilt natürlich nicht für alle schulen sondern das sind so einzelne sachen die wir sehen
schnell versucht wird sowas wie fern lehre aufzustellen wo die lehrer und alle rund rum die unglaublichsten sachen machen.
Und.
Ich denke auch das ist das was man zumindest dann so aus zweiter hand oder aus dritter hand hört dass es aber auch viele gibt die tatsächlich eine kollegin sagte die die abtauchen kollegen die einfach ich glaube nicht aus faulheit sondern eher aus unsicherheit teilweise auch wirklich gar nicht wissen was sie tun sollen
die ansage ist ja,
die schule ist zwar als haus geschlossen aber die lehrerin sollen weiter kontakt zu den schülern halten und vielleicht auch versuchen sowas wie unterrichts ersatz zu machen und das wird glaube ich in den unterschiedlichsten dimensionen gerade gemacht.
Hallo,
was ist denn dir da so vorgekommen als ich kann vielleicht mal so aus meiner eigenen situation berichten ich habe halt ein kind noch einer grundschule eins schon gymnasium und
na ja es läuft eigentlich bei beiden vergleichbar im wesentlichen ist es so eine permanente hausaufgaben,
beschickung so das ganze läuft mehr oder weniger über e-mail mit den entsprechenden problemen die das so mit sich bringt die vielleicht noch überschaubar sind.
Aber es ist halt auch ein sehr indirekter doppelt indirekter kontakt weil das dann eben das weiß ich also in unserem fall
geht es dann an so eine kontaktperson die das dann auf die mailingliste packt die wir schon vorher eingerichtet hatten
wo alle eltern drauf sind so da muss man sich das dann eben so runterholen und das dann wiederum den kindern zu führen also es ist nicht so dass die kinder auf einer mailingliste werden oder so dazu müssen sie ja auch alle erstmal e-mail haben
und naja und dann soll irgendwann das mal wieder zurückgeschickt werden und es ist so dieses typische bäcker meine jeder der mal mit mailingliste gearbeitet hat und versucht darüber irgendwie,
klare anweisungen zu erhalten oder jederzeit zahlt sich merken zu können was er jetzt eigentlich gerade zu wann gefordert war schreit eben schnell eigentlich mal nach etwas effizienteren
methoden und in der arbeitswelt.
Erleben wir das ja nun schon seit längerer zeit nicht dass halt computergestützt eine ganze menge sachen passieren aber das ist sozusagen sage ich will jetzt noch nicht so sehr auf das digitale hinaus sondern überhaupt erstmal nur ein einblick ist aus meiner perspektive liefern wie es denn überhaupt läuft
in dem rahmen würde ich sagen aus meiner ganz persönlichen privaten perspektive natürlich.
Ok so es herrscht ruhe und tickets haben in gewisser hinsicht was zu tun
je nach charakter ist es halt etwas leichter oder etwas schwerer zu dieser hausaufgaben orientierten arbeiten auch aufzurufen aber das
aber dann auch nicht so sehr viel anders als normalerweise auch.
Also das ist tatsächlich glaube ich ein relativ verbreiteter fall so dieses irgendwie aufgaben verschicken.
Was übrigens ja viel leichter ist als aufgaben danach wieder einsammeln weil in dem ersten fall hat man mandy,
irgendwie das das geht noch beziehungsweise es wird auch sozusagen verteilt das problem beispielsweise mit den eltern gesagt wird gebt das mal weiter oder auch sowas wie druck das mal aus was erstaunlich viele eltern glaube ich vor große herausforderungen stellt.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Der rückkanal ist dann tatsächlich viel schwieriger wie wird das wieder eingesammelt und wenn wir jetzt vielleicht sagen naja vielleicht gehört dazu noch mehr nämlich.
Direkte rückmeldungen gespräche kontakt halten etcetera ist ja mehr als aufgabenverteilung einsammeln da wird es viel unübersichtlicher und schwieriger,
insofern sehen wir da auch glaube ich die gemischte bilder von den lehrern die wirklich jeden tag gucken dass sie mit jedem schüler gesprochen haben.
Ich habe davon kolleginnen und kollegen gehört die sagen irgendwie ok sie morgens um sieben geht's los und abends um zehn halb elf sind noch die letzten nachrichten die sie mit den schülerinnen schreiben.
Gesprochen im sinne von telefonate geführt oder e-mail kontakt gehabt.
Ich glaube das ist auch sehr gemischt also tatsächlich jeden tag kontakt gehabt wäre vielleicht so das große ziel und welche kanäle dabei genutzt werden ist,
glaube ich total spannend es gibt ja in den bundesländern jeweils so eigene lösungen teilweise auch so halbe lösungen wie in schulen kommuniziert werden kann da haben die dann irgendwie ihre eigenen lernplattform teilweise pro schule teilweise pro bundesland teilweise gar nicht.
Und darüber läuft es.
In manchen bundesland glaube ich ein bisschen besser und in vielen bundesländern eher schlechter also.
Wenn man jetzt nicht eine offizielle befragung macht sondern eher sozusagen guckt was machen die wirklich dann läuft glaube ich einfach das allermeiste über whatsapp realistisch gesehen wenn sie tatsächlich direkt kontakt haben wollen wir retten wahrscheinlich jetzt auch eher dann von von,
etwas größeren kindern also vielleicht nicht unbedingt grundschule also was wirklich ein große.
Zuspruch erfährt sind sozusagen die nicht für bildung gedacht medien das ist ja in deutschland vielleicht auch mal besonders extrem dass man,
extra software extra dienste extra anbieter sich ausgewählt hat und nicht sagte wie wir kommunizieren über den messenger die vision haben sondern man muss es halt irgendwie bildungsmesse wieder schulmessen geben etcetera,
das blöde ist nur die funktionieren halt in der regel.
Zumindest schlechter die erreichbarkeit von den schülerinnen ist schlechter und die systeme sind auch total schnell überlastet gewesen also.
Kenne ich jetzt aus einzelnen bundesländern nur wo wirklich sehr schnell sehr viele lehrerinnen frustriert waren und gesagt haben sie verbieten uns ja irgendwie whatsapp zu nutzen aber über ihren dienst geht's halt auch gar nicht also ihren dienst dann halt das was die länder jeweils anbieten.
Wenn es so einen dienst gibt von dem ich jetzt überrascht bin dass er sehr viel sehr schnell zuspruch findet übrigens dann ist es tatsächlich teams also microsoft stunde scheint wieder nochmal geschlagen zu haben,
das habe ich vorher nur so aus einzelnen schulen gehört das ist jetzt was was.
Einen relativ vielen schulen schnell aufgesetzt wurde.
Vielleicht auch weil es von vielen kollegen ohne große absprache in der schule einzeln aufgesetzt werden konnte.
Auch da ist natürlich nicht repräsentativ was ich irgendwie so wahrnehme aber teams sehr auffällig und ich bin noch nicht so sicher warum.
Welche komponente wird denn da vor allem benutzt also der chat.
Tatsächlich messenger chat aber auch video-chat und tatsächlich auch datei bereitstellung was was da immer schon zu sehen war aber.
Ich jetzt auch nicht so aus meiner eigenen erfahrung oder sowas besonders intensiv kannte ich nehme an es ist halt so diese mischung aus,
microsoft hat irgendwie ja seltsam weise immer noch in den schulen sondern ok standing also wenn du in schulen sagst wie wir nutzen hier eine cloud-lösung von google ist es ganz böse wenn du das gleiche von microsoft sagst irgendwie noch okay.
Ja das stimmt.
Es gleichzeitig auch so von der usability irgendwie ist es vielleicht für die schüler jetzt irgendwie nicht so komfortabel wie whatsapp nutzen aber sie kommen damit irgendwie klar.
Vielleicht ist es schon so einfach dass das so die ersten erklärungen wären.
Der hat auch schon mal den vorteil dass es halt auch auf oft auf laptops ordentlich zu betreiben ist diese ganzen smartphone
messenger etcetera das ist ganz nett um sich mal ein paar kleine nachrichten und lustige bildchen und vielleicht mal ein video um die ohren zu schmeißen aber wenn man halt wirklich,
kennst du das ja auch ne also wenn man mal wirklich so mit text arbeitet etcetera da will man ja jetzt nicht schon lange so ein telefon an so einem text arbeiten da ist man schon mal froh wenn man mal ein fenster groß ziehen kann und sprich letzten endes hat man seinen ganzen datei kram den man benutzt und erstellt
ohnehin auf dem rechner und dann ist halt auch das schreiben mit der tastatur am ende viel entspannter,
ja ich meine es ist interessant ne dass ich sozusagen schulen dann auf einmal genauso wiederfinden in so einer situation wie man das dann eben später in der arbeit.
Eigentlich auch jetzt hat ne man ist ein team,
es gibt einen teamleiter aber eigentlich sind dann in der kommunikation ja auch alle irgendwie gleich ne.
Ja das ist tatsächlich auch was was ich so von vielen ecken höre so dass sich da auch neue rollen ausbilden also beispielsweise wenn man irgendwie eine technische umgebung hat wo jeder schüler genauso viel zu sagen hat wie ein lehrer.
Dann sagen die teilweise auch genauso viel aber auch umgekehrt dass einfach,
schüler das ist glaube ich ein größeres problem als wir so denken tatsächlich unsichtbar werden also wenn die in der schule auch wenn die möglicherweise ganztag nichts gesagt haben und der lehrer auch nicht zu ihnen gesprochen hat dann waren die zumindest da und es gab so ein bisschen soziale kontrolle.
Es den zumindest nicht katastrophal schlecht geht und vielleicht haben wir es auch oft nicht gemerkt das weiß ich nicht aber im moment jemand der dann tatsächlich nicht dabei ist also unsichtbar ist im sinne von der lehrer hat von dem heute nichts gesehen nichts gehört keinen kontakt gehabt,
der ist ja komplett nicht dabei abgehängt und möglicherweise auch gar nicht erreicht also da,
bin ich sehr unsicher wie groß der anteil ist es gibt glaube ich viele aber ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt um fünf prozent oder um um dreißig prozent der schüler geht die tatsächlich plötzlich unsichtbar werden
mit allem was da möglicherweise noch hinten dranhängt wir sprechen ja inzwischen relativ viel über die probleme mit häuslicher gewalt et cetera das kann man sich schon vorstellen dass
soziale kontrolle wegfällt weil vielleicht der.
Nimm mal gleich das volle klischee der schläger vater irgendwie halt sonst noch irgendwie vielleicht noch die bremse hat okay das kind ist morgen in der schule und wird da gesehen wenn jetzt nicht mal mehr das passiert.
Denke ich dass wir da tatsächlich relativ viel elend gerade nicht sehen.
Was ja ein gutes argument wäre solche beschulung aus der ferne auch durchaus mit videokameras zu machen also sprich hier auch diese videokonferenz situation zu nutzen.
Ja also der großartige schweizer pädagoge philipp der jetzt jeden tag quasi auf youtube lockt,
mit ganz einfachen videos der hat in einem video sehr klar dafür plädiert dass diese ganzen formate mit live konferenz und sprechen miteinander etcetera,
komplett für das in anführungszeichen soziale genutzt wird um im gespräch zu bleiben um in kontakt zu bleiben etcetera und es vollkommen sekundär ist darüber dann sowas wie lernen unterricht übungen abzuwickeln das kannst du ganz gut wie.
Tim wie du es gerade beschrieben hast auch offline machen also im zweifelsfall offensichtlich auch derzeit viel auf papier,
wenn man sozusagen auf irgendwas verzichten könnte dann vielleicht das auch noch die übung online stattfinden müssen aber das kontakt halten das ist wahrscheinlich entscheidender in dem fall.
Ja und ich muss auch sagen das ist das ist das was ich eigentlich am meisten vermisst habe also im fall des.
Das kind ist mit gymnasium gab es jetzt in der ganzen zeit wenn ich das richtig sehe nur ein einziges mal wirklich so ein telefonischen kontakt,
der halt auch erstmal nur so über ruft mich an wenn ihr fragen habt gelaufen ist und am ende wurden dann nochmal so alle abgeklappert die sich nicht von sich aus gemeldet haben dass man zumindest mal so die stimme hört,
also vielleicht keine vorwürfe machen ich sage nur alle alle unter druck nur das ist natürlich dann eben dann doch schon ein bisschen dünner weil irgendwann so dann die schule natürlich auch sehr,
fernbleibt weil man weil man eben nicht mehr so in kontakt treten einfach nur noch in so einem in so einem so einem drucker fütterer
für aufgaben verwandelt wird so ja schule ist das da kommt da kommt ja immer die neuen aufgaben jeden tag aus dem drucker raus und nichts anderes ne.
Und wenn die schulen jetzt nach den osterferien geschlossen bleiben dann glaube ich muss man tatsächlich gucken dass wir da auch einen anderen fokus hinkriegen also ich bin gar nicht
dagegen dass die da irgendwie aufgaben verschicken und bearbeiten und so weiter das ist ja quasi ein stabilisierender element auch für für die kinder und jugendlichen und vielleicht auch für die lehrer und vielleicht sogar auch für die eltern.
Es ist aus meiner sicht im moment nur so mittel zum zweck es geht im moment aus meiner sicht überhaupt nicht darum dass man in irgendwelche weise nicht irgendeinen stoff durch kriegt oder zurückfällt wenn man jetzt ein halbes jahr da irgendwie seine mattenübungen nicht vernünftig macht oder sowas.
Ich glaube dass die stresssituation die den familien entstehen noch viel härter werden können noch viel breiter sich ausbreiten können als dass wir es im moment vorstellen.
Muss klar sein wie der fokus muss darauf achten dass wir irgendwie.
Zumindest nicht noch zum stress beitragen wenn's gut läuft tatsächlich auch gucken dass wir mit allen kontakt halten und sehen wem es wirklich richtig schlecht geht.
Und stoff durchkriegen das finde ich wirkt angesichts der aktuellen umstände immer banaler.
Auch die ganzen sachen mit den prüfungen das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger aber auch da muss man sagen im moment.
Für unter den aktuellen umständen nur zu noch mehr sozialer ungleichheit in dem fall können wir vielleicht auch mal gleich darüber sprechen.
Schauen wir doch mal vielleicht auf die probleme die jetzt so unmittelbar entstehen mal sortiert nach den einzelnen betroffenen gruppen und fangen wir vielleicht mal bei den lehrern mal an.
Wie war's ja noch ist es ja nur auch nicht einfach was siehst du da passieren.
Also ich greife mal erst ich sage
paar konkrete beispiele und dann greife ich aber davor nochmal deine frage auf weil du sagst ja was siehst du da gerade und das ist genau dieser punkt wir sehen die lehrer die super
engagiert unterwegs sind beispielsweise auf twitter also diese hashtag twitter lehrerzimmer der sich da in den letzten jahren etabliert hat der brummt der geht gerade durch die decke die sind da wahnsinnig engagiert und im austausch und zwar nicht im sinne von,
irgendwie sich irgendwelche luft gebilde ausdenken sondern auch ganz handfest so hier ich brauche da und der unterstützung hat jemand erfahrung damit kann mir jemand tipp geben wie das und das et cetera also auf.
Der ebene läuft es extrem viel wird ganz viel gemeinsam gearbeitet rausgekriegt etcetera,
eine lehrerin mit der ich letzte woche sprach sagte gerade sie ist abends so dermaßen fertig weil sie hat in ihrem leben noch nicht so viel pro tag gelernt wie jetzt gerade.
Für die ist das ja größtenteils eben auch eine ganz neue situation teilweise ganz neue technologie oder dienste mit denen die dann arbeiten und ähm.
Da passiert sehr sehr viel auch.
Teilweise bizarr großartige sachen hier in hamburg gibt es,
der stadtteilschule wo der schulleiter jetzt jeden tag die dulsberger late night show über youtube produziert.
Und dann mit den mit den schülern teilweise irgendwie auch videokonferenzen macht und daraus youtube shows macht etcetera.
Teilweise wo die mit studenten zusammenarbeiten und denen dann aufgaben in briefumschlägen nach hause bringen.
Also auch da würde ich sagen.
Macht die not teilweise sehr erfinderisch und ich möchte übrigens ja sagen weil das sich auch auf twitter viel darüber lustig gemacht wurde über die sachen die da auf papier ausgetragen werden das ist halt tatsächlich erstens in vielen fällen notwendig,
weil nicht alle kinder irgendwie zuhause einen wunderbaren schreibtisch liebevolle eltern unten drucker haben sondern möglicherweise nichts von dem teilweise auch nicht mal einen laptop es gibt viele familien in denen nur mit smartphones internetzugang besteht,
und dann auch nur bis das datenvolumen alle ist und das mit dem papier,
ist halt teilweise das was was funktioniert also du hast zumindest dann wenn du lehrer und schüler hast die gelernt haben wie sie mit diesem papier aufgaben umgehen
jetzt nicht noch ein riesensprung dabei dass sie jetzt auch noch ganz neue technologien kennenlernen müssen wenn das halt mit papier moment funktioniert dann sollten sie so weitermachen und.
Nochmal sie sind ja auch nicht die einzigen ne also ich habe noch einmal letzter stand vor einer stunde nachgefragt bei einem professor an der fan hagen des fern- und hagen modell ist auch immer noch bei erwachsenen sodass die papier verschicken also.
Ich glaube es ist jetzt belegt wenn wenn wir uns darüber lustig machen würden dass die sachen auf papier machen.
Es werden da auch sehr schnell so angebote aufgebaut wo lehrer ihr wissen nochmal strukturiert austauschen in der schweiz lernen trotz korona punkt c innerhalb von ein paar tagen aus dem boden gestampft worden was für mich so eine der,
vielleicht die erste anlaufstelle ist wo ich irgendwie lehrerinnen und lehrer am hinschicken würde für ganz viel praktische sachen wie man das umsetzen kann wenn man jetzt aus dem home-office,
home bleaching quasi macht also wirklich ganz viel.
Was ich mich bei lehrern wirklich frage ist wie groß ist dieser anteil den wir nicht sehen von lehrern weil lehrer die auf twitter sind ich sage mal da geht's wahrscheinlich um ungefähr ein prozent aller lehrer die überhaupt auf twitter aktiv sind.
Diejenigen genau die da jetzt dann irgendwie auch noch aktiv sind und diesen großen schwung verbreiten da reden wir jetzt von irgendwie nachkommastellen promillebereich.
Und was die anderen neunundneunzig prozent machen ist sehr schwer einzuschätzen was ich aus den schulen höre ist so ein sehr gemischtes bild.
Das schon viele sich auch sehr bemühen auch sehr sehr sehr viele jetzt erste schritte machen überhaupt erst den digitalisierung aber auch viele quasi abtauchen und.
Wie gesagt unterstell ich gar keine bösen willen sondern tatsächlich mehr so eine unsicherheit.
Oder auch eine überforderung.
Genau eine überforderung bis hin zu dass die dann in der opposition gehen also
ganz viel gesagt wird na ja wir haben halt die schlechte ausstattung und hätten wir doch in den letzten jahren was geändert und der datenschutz und so weiter das sind alles sachen die man im einzelnen irgendwie begründet diskutieren kann aber das hilft im moment gerade nicht also.
Ich glaube dass da tatsächlich viel philipp hat sie in seinem videoblog genannt sozusagen aus der überforderung dann so in die opposition gegangen wird und er hat die lehrer dann aufgefordert dass er sagt
wenn ihr gerade hilfe braucht dann sagt wir brauchen ihre hilfe wir wissen ja nicht weiter das überfordert uns.
Wenn ihr aber sagt irgendwie das was die engagierten leute machen ist alles doof dann können wir euch gerade nicht helfen und das problem ist dass es ja nicht ihr lehrer dies dann aus badet sondern eure schüler.
Wahrscheinlich ein sehr gutes argument.
Ich glaube der größte punkt dahinter ist wirklich zu sagen es ist von außen wirklich schwer zu sehen wie diese verteilung ist wie viel lehrerin lehrerin da gerade was machen strukturiert ist es gar nicht also.
Ich glaube es geht auch nicht zu strukturieren zumindest nicht innerhalb von ein paar wochen da wird zwar viel geschimpft über politik oder schulbehörde etcetera.
Das bild ist glaube ich da auch da sehr gemischt ich würde jetzt sagen wenn man mir vorher gesagt hätte wie es jetzt aussieht.
Eher überrascht dass es teilweise konstruktiv und schneller läuft auch in den behörden als man es vielleicht erwarten würde.
Ich glaube es ist ein vorteil dass es dass wir es jetzt auch mit einer krise zu tun haben in der wirklich ausnahmslos alle betroffen sind
es ist einfach keiner keiner kann sich sozusagen mit einem jahr ist mir doch egal was ihr für probleme habt dem entziehen und das business bevor bevorzugen weil gibt halt
eben kein mehr und das sicherlich ganz hilfreich und dann sind natürlich immer die kräfte die natürlich die minderheit sind die jetzt so voran
pirschen haben natürlich dann auch schon so ein bisschen die energie den rest mitzuziehen insofern kann es wahrscheinlich etwas,
erklären trotzdem und ich glaube das hat so ein bisschen auch was damit zu tun dass du es nicht unbedingt so erwartet hast ist es ja eigentlich auch in der
im lehrer bereich so ein bisschen ähnlich also schwieriger vergleich aber ich werde gleich wissen was ich meine wie im gesundheitswesen
dass das so ein bereich ist der schon immer irgendwie total wichtig war aber auch immer chronisch unterfinanziert schlecht bezahlt war gepaart mit hohen erwartungen
so nach dem motto ja rette mich jetzt beschult mich so ja
ohne dass dann eben auch das mit der passenden dankbarkeit oder zumindest bezahlung verbunden war und jetzt in so einer notsituation
während man zu dem gesundheitssystem so okay jetzt begebt euch mal rein in den solchen nebel und helft
den lehrern dann halt genauso so ja okay jetzt mit noch schlechteren bedingungen bitte nochmal das gleiche zum quadrat.
Also ich würde jetzt glaube ich nicht unterschreiben dass lehrer in deutschland schlecht bezahlt sind also so eine grundschule schulleitung vielleicht schon verhältnismäßig aber ansonsten.
Jetzt nicht daran sehen aber was auf jeden fall richtig ist dass es eine extreme verdichtung von aufgaben in deren alltag gibt.
Ich meine mit fördermitteln finden nicht unbedingt jetzt das gehalt sondern sozusagen auch diese gesamtausstellung womit kann ich arbeiten was für freiräume habe ich eigentlich überhaupt das was von mir erwartet wird auch zu leisten mit entsprechenden mitteln.
Diese ausnahmesituation lass uns dann nachher auch nochmal drüber sprechen was dann sozusagen bleibt wenn wir wieder in einem normalen zustand zurückkehren würden aber das ist schon ein spannendes verhältnis weil vieles was bisher business as usual war.
Ganz viel merken dass das gar nicht so selbstverständlich ist wie wir es immer gesehen hatten weil wir plötzlich sehen oh das geht ja auch anders also ganz viele dinge waren ja tatsächlich vorher gar nicht,
wie wir sie jetzt machen.
Ganz viele sachen sehen wir auch wie schwierig die auch im alltag schon werden beispielsweise jeden schüler einzeln im blick zu behalten ist ja auch schon vorher eine radikale überforderung gewesen.
Aber im moment sehen wir halt wie schwierig und wie aufwendig das ist und wenn wir als gesellschaft das verlangen von schule dass sie da jeden schüler einzeln im blick behält dann sehen wir jetzt gerade was für eine hohe anforderungen das ist wie schwierig,
wir als gesellschaft vielleicht der schule da irgendwie auch den ressourcen dafür gegeben habe oder wie viel wir von schule verlangen vielleicht erstmal.
Ja genau so videokonferenz mit dreißig leuten oh mein gott.
Jeden tag und dann möglicherweise noch fünfundvierzig minuten tag wechseln und jeweils die nächste videokonferenz mit der nächsten gruppe.
Mit anderen genau wie alle anderen das heißt alle ganz andere anforderungen hab ja stimmt.
Auch da sieht man auch dieses,
viele sachen die da selbstverständlich sind beispielsweise dieser fünfundvierzig minuten rhythmus neunzig minuten rhythmus meinetwegen oder sowas dass der halt auch an ganz vielen,
enden gar nicht sinnvoll ist ne also jetzt merken wir wo der sozusagen nicht sein muss weil die können zu hause ja irgendwie ohne schulglocke arbeiten.
Bestimmte sachen funktionieren auch anders und möglicherweise in anderen taktung vielleicht sogar besser.
Umgekehrt ist auch interessant zu sehen wie haben wir denn bisher gedacht wie wir sehen das lernen stattfindet habe ich mich vorgestern mit jemandem darüber unterhalten
sagte naja wir haben eigentlich immer nur vom vom leeren darauf geschlossen das wohl auch lernen stattfindet wenn du durch eine schule gehst und sagen würdest hast du gesehen ob da lernen stattfindet dann kannst du es in der traditionellen schule daran beobachten dass da halt irgendwie lehrer vorne standen was erzählt haben und dann haben wir den,
rückschluss gezogen dann lernen die wohl auch.
Das war ja wahrscheinlich schon immer eine illusion nur weil die meisten nach vorne gucken und die augen aufhaben und vielleicht auch noch freundlich gucken dass du tatsächlich irgendwie im kopf irgendwas von dem passieren würde was sich der lehrer die lehrerin vorne gedacht hat.
Das sieht man jetzt natürlich noch extremer dadurch dass der lehrer ja eigentlich immer noch sagt er kann input geben und aufgaben verteilen etcetera trotzdem überhaupt keinen direkten einfluss drauf hat was bei den schülern im kopf passiert das finde ich schon enorm spannend.
Es gibt ja auch schöne schöne kleine
twitter clips wo teenager zeigen wie sie die teilnahme an der videokonferenz faken indem sie ihr smartphone vor die webcam hängen video von sich das drückt es natürlich ganz schön aus
schau mal vielleicht mal auf die situation der eltern.
Das regt mich am meisten auf an dieser ganzen sache dass wir wirklich in diesen ganzen ard zdf extra berichten nur gefühlt berichte aus dem umkreis wahrscheinlich der journalisten sehen die diese berichte machen.
Und die kennen wahrscheinlich nur familien ich spitze mal ein bisschen zu aber es ist ein wesentlich in die richtige richtung glaube ich,
das sind immer familien wo es in der regel zwei elternteile gibt wo die kinder irgendwie einen laptop und einen schreibtisch zuhause haben und die eltern zwar darüber stöhnen dass sie da jetzt viel zu tun haben und das kind ab und zu dann irgendwie später in den garten gehen kann etcetera.
Was ich nie in irgendeinem sehr berichte gesehen habe seine familie in der mehrere kinder sichern zimmer teilen ist gar kein laptop gibt die eltern vielleicht nicht die sprache sprechen in der die aufgaben verfasst sind ist kein garten und auch kein balkon gibt etcetera.
Dazwischen gibt es wahrscheinlich noch sehr sehr viel bunter bereich.
Was aber tatsächlich einfach klar ist ist dass man nicht erwarten kann dass die eltern das alles auffangen also die eltern stehen ja auch in der regel enorm unter druck und haben enorm viel stress gerade.
Wenn sie jetzt irgendwie im zweifelsfall weiß ich nicht ihren system kritischen beruf.
Oder homeoffice noch irgendwie mit der betreuung der kleinkinder und der hausaufgabenbetreuung und zwar jetzt ja in acht stunden am tag hausaufgabenbetreuung der größeren kinder verbinden sollen.
Dann sorgt das natürlich für stress also ich finde dass man nicht im moment schule so planen kann dass die eltern ein,
tragender pfeiler in diesem system sind das ist super hilfreich wenn die eltern unterstützung bieten können aber ein,
konzept von dem was wir vorher unterricht nannten was wir jetzt auf diese situation übertragen indem man sagt na ja dann kommt es darauf an dass die eltern da hinterher sind auch gucken dass die schüler das machen et cetera
extrem sozial ungerecht und extrem stressvoll
weil es macht eben nur sinn bei den familien in denen das tatsächlich auch so funktioniert und die anderen haben damit noch viel größere probleme als sie vorher schon hatten.
Sorgt halt auch noch für unnötigen stress weil die haben in den familien echt schon dann genug stress und wenn jetzt noch hinzu kommt dass sie sich über matheaufgaben streiten müssen dann schüttele ich sehr stark den kopf.
Man macht sie auch manchmal gar nicht klar wie wichtig für das lernen eben dieses herausnehmen aus dem familiären kontext ist und.
Das jetzt das natürlich alles so auch zusammenkommen ich meine was zum beispiel gesagt system kritischer beruf.
Es gibt ja sicherlich auch viele leute die jetzt auch einfach gerade das problem haben dass sie entweder maximalfall arbeitslos geworden sind oder zumindest
für ihr unternehmen vielleicht auch ihr eigenes unternehmen gerade so vor dem ruin stehen den retten müssen et cetera also das sind natürlich dann aber auch wirklich extreme stresssituationen.
Also nochmal mein appell irgendwie liebe lehrerinnen und lehrer liebe system schule liebe gesellschaft insgesamt das ziel im moment muss es sein irgendwie stress entgegenzuwirken und nicht noch mehr stress zu machen.
Das ist wirklich aus meiner sicht das wichtigste gerade wenn das jetzt wirklich nach den osterferien nochmal so weitergeht und wir bei sechsundzwanzig grad und sonnenschein.
Alle drin halten müssen und der homeoffice vater neben direkt daneben sitzen also das wird kein spaß und.
Mathe übungen sind nicht das oberste ziel da kriegen wir ärger von allen mathelehrerin.
Das heißt aber auch dass das die eltern ein bisschen runterfahren sollten ich meine so dieses so oh jetzt sind aber die hausaufgaben das musst du dir jetzt rein takten.
Ja keine ahnung man weiß ja auch nicht so richtig den
die anforderungen einzuschätzen die jetzt gerade gestellt werden so geht es mir darum sie beschäftigt zu halten ist das jetzt wirklich kritisch jetzt haben wir auch noch das
problem dass wir so am ende der schulzeit
des schuljahres stehen und wenn ich weiß okay was schließt ja jetzt noch in irgendeiner bewertung oder note ein.
Also das ist ja auch alles schwer abzuwägen.
Also wenn ich da irgendwie bildungspolitische monarch wäre oder sowas.
Es gibt ja so vorschläge wie man sozusagen jetzt die prüfung ersetzt beispielsweise beim abitur dadurch dass man einfach die letzten jahre nimmt aus denen sich dann sowieso ein gewisser anteil der abiturnote zusammensetzt.
Und das dann als anhaltspunkt nimmt dass man zeugnisse irgendwie ich weiß nicht was zusammenbricht wenn man das jetzt mal für ein semester aussetzt,
etcetera also natürlich bricht viel zu der meinung man bricht überall ganz viel zusammen ich glaube nicht dass das dann der kritische punkt ist wo man sagen muss es jetzt das hat das fass zu überlaufen gebracht dass wir ein halbes jahr lang keine noten vergeben haben oder zumindest die nicht irgendwie relevanten ein zeugnis geschrieben haben ähm.
Das glaube ich tatsächlich könnte in den nächsten wochen nochmal klarer werden wenn die situation noch stressiger werden kann.
Bleiben aber auch noch die schüler als spieler in diesem spiel über die glaube ich relativ wenig gesprochen wird.
Da hast du recht also die sind ja tatsächlich die dann noch unsichtbarer drin in diesem system wir sehen dann vielleicht irgendwie in den familien auch unsere eigenen kinder,
etcetera aber.
Wenn man ein bisschen auf auf insta oder sowas guckt sieht man auch ein paar sachen aber auch das ist natürlich nicht eine abbildung von dem was tatsächlich in den familien passiert,
das ist total gemischt also was eine schülerin rechts getwittert hat fand ich sehr sehr zutreffend die stand jetzt offensichtlich kurz vor der abschlussprüfung und sagte sie hat zwölf jahre lang jeden tag gehofft dass die scheiß schule ausfällt und jetzt ist sie am heulen weil sie ausfällt.
Hallo.
Das fand ich sehr ja eigentlich tiefgehend also die entdecken jetzt ja sozusagen was sie überhaupt,
daran auch wertschätzen und jetzt vermissen an schule beispielsweise dass man dahingeht um sich mit leuten zu treffen und nicht dass man da hingeht um mathe übungen zu haben.
Das wird jetzt ja auch durch diesen ausnahmezustand nochmal viel klarer und ich vermute ganz stark tatsächlich dass viele schülerinnen und schüler auch freiwillig zur schule gehen würden wenn diese option geben würde.
Also auch die lernen ja da gerade ganz viel.
Sie lernen auch wofür es wichtig ist lehrer zu haben wofür es nicht wichtig ist lehrer zu haben was gut über das internet funktioniert was nicht gut funktioniert etcetera.
Sie lernen auch dass sie in diesem system die schwächsten sind also die können sich ja irgendwie tatsächlich jetzt wenn irgendwie.
Die schule sagte irgendwie jetzt sind aber die abschlussprüfung und die zeugnisse sind wichtig und deren eltern sagen das auch etcetera dann wird der druck einfach immer weiter durchgegeben und die schüler und schülerinnen sind diejenigen die nachher am ende der druck kette sitzen.
Was.
Bleibt denn jetzt sozusagen herauszunehmen aus dieser situation also man hat ja keinen.
Kein plan im schrank gehabt klar zu den den hatte niemand für diese situation andererseits kann man natürlich auch sagen.
Ja hättet ihr schon mal früher dieses und jenes getan das ist natürlich immer ein wohlfeiles argument in jede richtung.
Trotzdem wissen wir ja aber auch dass wir natürlich was dass die digitalisierung der schule betrifft schon lange eine sehr ausufernde debatte führen ohne dass man das gefühl hat schon irgendwo hin gegangen ist.
Also.
Du kennst die geschichte kennt sie nicht jeder und die katzenbilder also hat mal in denken an seiner vielen schlauchen bücher geschrieben dass die leute sich immer so darüber,
lustig machen dass menschen katzenbilder ins internet zu setzen und er sagte da der große unterschied ist nicht.
Ob die jetzt super ausgefeilte moos sophistication die inhalte schreiben oder ein katzenbild der große unterschied ist dieser erste schritt zwischen gar nichts ins internet schreiben und ein katzenbild reinsetzen danach ist graduell der anstieg möglich zu ausgefeilten inhalten.
Und wenn ich ich bin dann ist das vielleicht jetzt eine chance für viele lehrer und für die schulen dass jetzt ganz ganz ganz viele,
auf einen schlag ins kalte wasser gesprungen sind und sozusagen diesen ersten schritt gemacht haben und sich mal angeguckt hat wie funktioniert das mit der digitalisierung und wie es unterricht anders vorstellbar.
Dann das,
nicht zurückzudrehen ich glaube es ist schon möglich wenn es schlecht läuft dass es in anführungszeichen wieder vergessen wird aber der schwierigste einzelschuss war dieser von null auf schritt eins zu gehen
insofern könnte das schon helfen tatsächlich sehr viel in richtung von digitalisierung in schulen neu zu denken
aber auch in pädagogischer hinsicht ein bisschen weiter zu denken von mir von kurz erwähnte michael schatz
erziehungswissenschaftler im irritiert inzwischen auch sprecher der jury beim deutschen schulpreis und der hat gesagt der corona oder das corona virus könnte zu wirksamsten fortbildungsmaßnahme des jahrhunderts werden hat er gesagt
weil wir gerade so viel grundsätzlich über schule lernen weil wir sehen dass ganz viel eben nicht,
normal im sinne von gott gegeben ist oder von selbstverständlich ist sondern dass ganz viele sachen anders funktionieren dass es wichtig ist dass schülerinnen und schüler auch selbstständig lernen wenn nicht ein lehrer die ganze zeit guckt weil das müssen sie auch hier ganz weiteres leben lang.
Et cetera also wenn's gut läuft dann kann die schule tatsächlich sehr sehr viel aus diesem ausnahmezustand lernen.
Das sehe ich ja fast überall und ganz klar ne also gerade dieses.
Diese ablehnung die wir jetzt auch schon teilweise thematisiert haben so dem dem neuen und damit natürlich zu dem digitalen,
gegenüber dir so eingerissen wird weil man muss sich jetzt in gewisser hinsicht dann positionieren und man man man muss so ein minimum an kommunikation aufrecht erhalten wenn man irgendwie noch halbwegs mitspielen will oder dazu beitragen will dass irgendwas läuft
und wenn dann alle so ihr katzenbild moment haben und dann eben merken so okay.
Hat gar nicht weh getan zumindest nicht sehr vielleicht werden auch manche leute merken.
Oh mein gott es ist wirklich so schlimm wie ich immer dachte vielleicht sollte ich umschulen auf einen anderen beruf so aber,
jetzt wird zumindest mal was ausprobieren weil das ist glaube ich das was eigentlich mir auch persönlich immer gefehlt hat so diese mangelnde bereitschaft
einfach mal irgendwas auszuprobieren ohne sich gleich vorher in so endlosen diskussionen zu verfangen mit ob denn das überhaupt ginge und was sind dann wäre was sind daraus wieder resultieren könnte was man alles nicht weiß oder einfach in dem zuge.
Immer beschlossen hat letztlich gar nichts zu auszuprobieren und damit überhaupt gar keine erfahrung gemacht zu haben.
Also ich bin da voll bei dir dieses von schritt null auf den ersten schritt zu gehen total hilfreich,
teile jetzt nicht die euphorie die manche menschen auf twitter haben dass damit sozusagen automatisch eine positive richtung eingeschlagen ist weil
beispielsweise auch ganz viele lehrerinnen und lehrer gerade etwas entdecken nämlich wie wahnsinnig geil zur kontrolle geeignet die digitalen medien geeignet sind ne
wo dann einfach irgendwie dem schüler gesagt wird ich kann hier aber nur den lokfans sehen dass zuerst um drei uhr dreiundzwanzig deine hausaufgabe abgegeben hast.
Oder zu sehen irgendwie wer da was wie lange macht etcetera das sind ja sachen die in bestimmte richtung von pädagogik.
Feuchte träume hervorrufen und in meiner vorstellung einer offenen gesellschaft nicht so richtig kompatibel sind mit dem ziel dass wir die da zu mündigen menschen.
Bilden wollen also nur dass sie jetzt digital entdecken ist ein erster hilfreicher schritt wenn sie das jetzt aber auch noch irgendwie mit,
der modernen pädagogik und offenen gesellschaft als zielbild verbindende werde dort deutlich mehr geworden und da bin ich eben nicht so sicher also ich sehe schon
viele die sehr fasziniert sind von diesen ganzen kontrollmöglichkeiten und das muss ich jetzt dir nicht erklären und vielen der zuhörerin hier wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Aber man kann sich eine schule vorstellen die durch digitalisierung so dermaßen auf kontrolle und überwachung optimiert ist.
Wie man sich nicht mehr an science fiction filmen vor ein paar jahren hätte wahrscheinlich ausdenken können.
Ja gut ist natürlich auch die frage ob sich solche systeme dann überhaupt als erfolgreich herausbilden weil letztlich wird sich dann die sache ja auch ganz gut messen lassen und es wird auch immer andere modelle geben die sagen ja lass mal die zügel lockerer dann funktioniert das halt auch besser.
Guck mal ich meine wir hatten ja jetzt gerade in den letzten monaten da gab es ja die es fällt mir gerade der name der initiative nicht ein aber so eine digitalisierungsoffensive der bundesregierung die irgendwie ein paar milliarden in die hand.
Digitalpakt.
Der digitalpakt genau und naja das klang dann halt so ein bisschen mehr nach wir kaufen mal ein paar computer für die schulen und vielleicht kriegt ihr auch mal einen richtigen internetanschluss.
Hat uns das geholfen.
Also ist jetzt leicht gesagt irgendwie nie so gut wie gar nicht weil man weiß ja nicht wie es ohne noch schlimmer wäre.
Beim digitalpakt gab es schon so ein paar sachen wo man sagen muss das ist aber jetzt echt minimal irgendwie ein fortschritt.
Zumal man überlegt hat irgendwie was kann man jetzt damit kaufen und von der gelder vergabe dann bestimmte sachen einfacher und bestimmte sachen schwieriger waren und man hat halt natürlich liegt ja in eine tolle sache die sachen gekauft wo es einfacher war einfach zu kaufen war hardware.
Also das heißt es gibt relativ viele schulträger die irgendwie sehr sehr gerne diese interaktiven smartboard oder whiteboards für jede raum gekauft haben und da muss man sich dann sagen okay das ist nicht der große fortschritt den man sich erhofft hatte dass sie jetzt irgendwie halt powerpoint statt,
buntes tafelbild mit kreide machen oder so.
Was nicht daraus bezahlt worden konnte war personal oder fortbildung oder freistellung von lehrern dass die irgendwie freiraum haben wenn ihr stressigen alltag um sich selbst fortzubilden et cetera,
ich vermute dass es schon so eine grundausstattung braucht überall viel wlan hin ein paar geräte auch.
Ich glaube nicht dass an allen schulen für jeden schüler einen rechner erkauft werden muss dann kann ich mir eine bunte mischung an lösungen vorstellen et cetera.
Aber tatsächlich das was eigentlich bräuchte wären diese freiräume um darüber jetzt zu lernen und das nicht gerade nur in der corona krise um dreiundzwanzig uhr zuhause machen zu können.
Dafür waren noch gar keine möglichkeiten mit diesem digitalpakt geschaffen also da war halt irgendwie,
sehr viel beschaffung maßnahmen dann dahinter wo man gesagt hat ja hier,
wir können uns als politische entscheider vor dem smartboard fotografieren und dann steht in der zeitung hier der bildungspolitiker x hat,
dem digitalpackt und eigene mitteln ganz großartige sachen gemacht ist eine total digitale schule oder sowas,
damit jetzt irgendein fortschritt ist würde ich stark bezweifeln und salz schwer dich zu fotografieren irgendwie neben weil sie nicht neben dem wlan was du gekauft hast und zu sagen wir haben hier wlan gekauft,
bei vielen dann auch noch irgendwie erstmal große sorgen fallen kommen was machen denn die schüler da wenn sie jetzt auch noch wlan haben bei einer tafel kann man da sagen okay alles bleibt unter kontrolle der lehrer,
das ist digitalisierung wie sie sozusagen nicht so bedrohlich wirkt für das system und davon abgesehen dass ich auch noch sagen.
Fünf milliarden euro wenn man das dann auf schüler und jahr rum gerechnet hat und dann irgendwie reicht das auch nur so.
Kleinen kick zu geben aber auch nicht so als tragende säule also.
Immer noch ist es so dass lehrer lehrerin irgendwie sozusagen vor ein zwei drei stunden unterricht weniger,
dann teilweise die verwalten sollen von der sie ja gerade ganz viel neue anschaffen also es ist auch viel mehr wird.
Das muss man sich vorstellen irgendwie in irgendeinem anderen bereich keine ahnung sagen wir du bist investmentbanker irgendwo und irgendwie soll's dann bitte neben deinem broker abends nochmal das netzwerk verwalten es kommt einem total.
Albern vor aber in der schule organisieren das ist immer noch so.
Trotzdem ist natürlich die frage nach guter infrastruktur und was braucht bräuchten denn die schulen oder was bräuchten sie zumindest jetzt in dieser situation eigentlich durchaus legitim
bin halt jetzt verschiedene sachen also geräte hast ja schon angesprochen jetzt wäre es ja vor allem wichtig dass man sicherstellen kann.
Um eine teilnahme aus der ferne zu machen bräuchten schüler gerät und sowieso ein taschenrechner auch mitfinanziert wird oder zumindest billiger beschafft wird könnte man ja ein ähnliches modell auch für computer andenken.
Ja also da gibt es sehr viele verschiedene systeme und ich würde tatsächlich auch bei
bei so vielen schülern die wir haben jetzt nicht auf eins setzen sondern sagen naja vielleicht ist das in der grundschule anders als im gymnasium in reicheren stadtteil als in einer gesamtschule in schwierigeren stadtteil finanziell schwierigen stadtteil
ähm.
Was man tatsächlich braucht sind flexible lösungen also was jetzt in hamburg seit letzter woche ging dass die geräte die eigentlich nur in der schule verwendet durften jetzt auch tatsächlich mit nach hause gegeben werden dürften es war vorher verboten.
Was hast.
Da hat die hamburger schulbehörde.
Hier nochmal irgendwie flexibler als man vielleicht so denkt relativ schnell sowas gemacht wie ja okay hier das müssen die eltern schreiben und dann könnt ihr ein gerät mit nach hause nehmen das reicht in der regel aus wenn das im durchschnitt keine ahnung zwanzig prozent der schüler hat weil achtzig prozent haben vielleicht ein gerät.
Schwieriger wird es dann beim internetzugang zuhause da.
Ist das glaube ich nicht im schulsystem alleine getan dass man da irgendwie lösungen schaffen können musste.
Wir kriegen jetzt ja nicht auf die schnelle wahrscheinlich irgendwie ja es ist eine normale router systeme da irgendwie in der fläche verteilt.
Was für ein gutes thema entschuldigung.
Nomadische die die du also diese ich weiß gar nicht kann du produkt namen gigacube oder sowas.
Ach du meinst du eine verbindung sozusagen als internet.
Würde mir durchaus als option vorkommen also dass man einfach sagt so hier ist einfach ein fertiger router da ist da ist eine schule schüler schüler ec-karte ja telekom sport
sponsort da einfach mal zwanzig gigabyte drauf damit geht dann auch die videokonferenz auf jeden fall durch und die dinger sind.
Vielleicht auch remote administriert sozusagen von so einer schulart ministrant nicht um da jetzt so firewalls einzustellen sondern einfach sicherzustellen funktioniert man kann den auch von außen helfen
ohne da jetzt wieder über telekom zu gehen das sind dann details aber,
wenn das eine wichtige infrastruktur ist warum nicht weil es auch nicht so teuer also es vor allem alles sehr überschaubare investitions dinger und würde dann halt mal eben so schlapp das problem mit internet zuhause lösen.
Also ich glaube für für die aktuelle krise ist es auch sehr schwierig weil du halt nicht weißt du musst jetzt irgendwas planen für drei wochen oder drei monate oder länger.
Dadurch hängst du natürlich immer ein bisschen daher weil du dann wenn du entscheidest da okay wir wissen jetzt es wird doch monate dauern dann ist schon wieder ganz schön viel zeit vergangen ähm.
Aber vielleicht gucken wir irgendwie in einem monat und sagen ja es wäre doch sinnvoll dass irgendwie jetzt so anzuschaffen die die frage was das
langfristig bringt ist denn tatsächlich nochmal eine andere weil ich glaube tatsächlich dass da auch wenn da internet da ist das größte problem wird immer noch sein dass.
Für diese große ungerechtigkeit haben im schulsystem das ist so viel davon abhängig ist wie viel support
die schülerinnen zuhause kriegen und damit mein ich jetzt nicht technischen support sondern beispielsweise hilfe bei den hausaufgaben oder auch nur die situation dass du da in ruhe sitzen und deine hausaufgaben machen kannst weil du nicht drei geschwister mit dir hast und kein schreibtisch und so weiter.
Da kommst du dann nicht mehr mit technischen lösungen hin sondern da brauchst du halt sowas wie nachmittags angeboten in der schule dass du halt deine hausaufgaben da machen kannst oder andere schultag wo du keine hausaufgaben mehr hast weil du irgendwie vormittags und nachmittags irgendwie rhythmisiert den unterricht hast.
Da hilft uns auch der router nicht so mehr.
Andere frage war noch bei digitaler schule struktur sind,
es ist natürlich auch so die frage nach schulklasse also da kommen wir dann auch gleich so in die frage mit welche werkzeuge
sollen denn eigentlich wirklich so zum einsatz kommen hast du so einen überblick welche schulen sowas überhaupt haben also dass sie quasi so eine eigene server infrastruktur haben also die frage
wo werden dann die daten abgelegt etcetera ne wo kommen diversen pfeils hin
wieviel von dieser in anführungsstrichen offenen infrastruktur des internets benutzen wir denn jetzt wo liegen denn die daten am ende jetzt ich will jetzt keine datenschutz diskussion aufmachen ist aber auch einfach manchmal ganz,
frage mit zugang sichern backups einfach auch irgendwie seinen seinen eigenen betrieb für sich selbst sicherstellen zu können weil kann auch nicht sein dass irgendein anbieter morgen pleite geht und dann ist alles weg und dann dann steht die schule da und hat irgendwie ein jahr lang
der arbeit der schüler verloren also das ist ja sozusagen auch eine gewisse selbstverantwortung die da mit hochgehalten werden muss gibt's sowas was schon und wie siehst du das.
Also es ist die freundlich gesagt bunteste landschaft die man sich vorstellen kann also von schulen die da total professionell unterwegs sind.
Bis zur schulen die gar nichts machen in schulen in den einzelnen lehrer was machen und das aufgesetzt haben und die schulleitung weiß gar nicht was da eigentlich passiert bis zum bundesländern in denen das versucht wird sehr stark runterzubrechen also bayern versucht er schon stark
durchzusetzen dass die irgendwie alle auch ihr model haben in den schulen und so weiter das sind zentral administriert wird.
Nudel ist so eins der open source lernen werkzeuge.
Genau und bayern hat sich da so seine eigene anpassung gebaut und hat halt den vorteil dass es erstmal einigermaßen funktioniert.
Er hat den nachteil dass es dann nur noch so mittel flexibel ist und dass die schulen dann nur noch begrenzt auswahl haben es ist halt dann die frage na willst du dass die schulen was aussuchen können was gut zu ihnen passt oder willst du möglichst für viele schulen eine stabile lösung haben.
Es gibt auch ja die bemühungen des bundesweit zu machen das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig föderalistischen gesehen das bundesministerium für bildung und forschung hat in den letzten jahren sehr viel geld gegeben ans hasso plattner institut für die entwicklung einer sogenannten schulklasse.
Wo man auch nicht so richtig weiß irgendwie was ist da jetzt irgendwie so die politik dahinter wenn sechzehn bundesländer das machen erhofft man sich davon einfach mit einer siebzehnten lösung dann den großen wurf zu machen oder hat man danach einfach nur siebzehn lösungen statt sechzehn.
Da ist jetzt gerade ein sogenanntes sondervermögen vom bundesministerium für bildung und forschung auf den weg gebracht worden dass diese schulklug vom pc mehr schulen zur verfügung gestellt werden soll.
Bin ich gespannt was daraus wird das was man aus der praxis darüber hört ist sehr sehr gemischt und sehr schwer einzuordnen weil.
Von außen manchmal glaube dass es tatsächlich auch sehr sehr gut darin ist öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu betreiben und.
Traue ich mir nicht richtig ein urteil zu was langsam beginnt ist das was in deutschland ja tatsächlich immer ganz früh thema war die öffnung für die großen kommerziellen anbieter.
Also dass man tatsächlich in den ersten bundesländern zumindest hinter vorgehaltener hand hört na ja jetzt machen wir eine ausschreibung und werden amazon die gewinnt mit allen ausschreibungen bedingungen die wir aufgestellt haben dann hat halt amazon die gewonnen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich sehr deutscher sonderweg dass man das immer für sehr problematisch hält.
Ich finde das nicht unproblematisch das irgendwie amazon google apple und microsoft dann irgendwie da die cloud lösung und sowas bereitstellen man darf sich nur nicht vormachen dass halt.
Wenn man es nicht macht man gar keine probleme da hätte also wenn man halt irgendwie sonne selbst gefrickelt die lösung hat die hier irgendwie auf dem server im keller betrieben wird und es gibt zwei informatiker die wissen wie es funktioniert und zwei schüler die auch zugang haben etcetera
glaube ich ist es weder mit der datensicherheit noch mit dem datenschutz ganz frei von problemen mal freundlich gesagt.
Ja vor allem das kann er auch noch sehr viel schneller wegbrechen als ein internationaler konzern.
Wie gesagt ich will jetzt nicht ein großes plädoyer mit wir übergeben jetzt irgendwie komplett unsere infrastruktur den großen konzernen.
Aber im moment.
Das ist kein plädoyer sondern eher eine prognose kann ich mir vorstellen dass es in den nächsten jahren eine große offenheit für gibt weil man halt sieht dass man mit diesen selbstgestrickten lösungen.
Ausreichend weit kommt sieht man jetzt in der krise ja auch ganz stark dass einfach die lösungen die dann da die landen anbieten etcetera total überlastet sondern nicht ausreichend sind et cetera ähm,
das was funktioniert hat sich jetzt so banal an aber es ist für die praxis natürlich extrem folgenreich das was funktioniert sind whatsapp und dropbox tut mir leid.
Dann haben halt irgendwie viel lehrerinnen und lehrer nicht die wahl
nutzen wir hier irgendwas super abgesicherter open source datenschutztechnisch dreimal geprüftes oder nutzen wir das böse whatsapp und dropbox sondern sie haben die wahl nutzen sie gar nichts oder nutzen sie whatsapp und dropbox.
Ja
Ja ich meine es ist ja nicht,
auch nur eine aufgabe die sich jetzt schulen und eine frage die sich schulen stellen müssen soll ich sehe da an der stelle auch wirklich dann
den bund mal in der pflicht mal darüber nachzudenken ob man nicht einfach mit diesen großen anbietern sagt so okay meinetwegen ja wir würden euren kram ja auch benutzen
hier ist ein spezifischer rahmenvertrages schule ihr müsst uns zusichern dass das und das und das und das und das.
Erfüllt ist ja also datenschutz hier begab da keine ahnung wieder verwertbarkeit exportiert zeit ja also so was vielleicht,
genau was in so einem normalen kunden verhältnis oder firmenfitness vielleicht nicht so wer wo aber der staat sagen kann so also erstmal.
Habt ihr das einfach zu tun sonst gehen wir da mal gesetzlich bei anderes thema sondern vielmehr so dass er würde euch die möglichkeit
öffnen halt auch in diesem schuhmarkt reinzugehen aber wenn wir uns nicht auch jederzeit wieder rausziehen und woanders reinschieben können dann könnte es auch gleich vergessen und dann,
werden die da auch irgendeine eine lösung finden die muss dann halt auch mal gesucht werden.
Also wenn ich voll bei dir.
Weil man ja schon sieht dass es irgendwie im rest der welt und den anderen systemen weil sie nicht von arztpraxen über banken über behörden über sonst was dafür lösungen gefunden werden können
natürlich irgendwie muss ich dir als letztes erzählen dass es da ganz schön viel schwierigkeiten gibt in diesen lösungen.
Aber zu sagen irgendwie schule sei ein so anderes system dass es da nicht denkbar ist das würde ich auch für quatsch halten und,
da wird sich sicher irgendwie in den nächsten mal sehen vielleicht auch jetzt durch die krone krise beschleunigt in den nächsten jahren wollte ich gerade sagen nochmal viel ändern.
Aber es ist schwierig in der schule weil es teilweise eine extrem irrationale diskussion ist wir hatten vorher ein kurzes beispiel mit irgendwie was für eine allergie hochgeht wenn der name google kommt.
Aber im moment ist ja tatsächlich so viel ich muss nur eine geschichte erzählen da was vorher gar nicht möglich war und zwar gibt es ja in deutschland die kultusministerkonferenz die kmh.
Erschienen vor drei vier tagen auf deren website ein quasi redaktionelle bericht also nicht wir haben hier einen beschluss oder sowas sondern ein,
das heißt bei denen natürlich nicht block aber so ein artikel quasi
und da stand hier empfehlungen für lernen trotz schulschließungen.
Waren dann einfach ganz viele sachen gesammelt also so eine kommentierte linkliste quasi von anbietern wo man,
quasi nicht mathe-videos kaufen konnte aber auch zu cloud-lösungen auch von google und microsoft drinne.
Und es hat dann lehrer getwittert und ich habe das auch nochmal getwittert und gesagt irgendwie guck mal hier,
das ist ja wahnsinn die kamen jetzt sowas hier macht oder auch sicherlich auch noch drüber schreibt irgendwie so quasi empfehlung der kmh und,
tatsächlich war am nachmittag danach dann auch schon irgendwie oben drüber geschrieben quasi rot blinkend metaphorisch gemeint rot blinkend achtung dass es keine offizielle empfehlung und google und microsoft waren aus der liste wieder verschwunden.
Aber dass es da überhaupt mal kurz stehen konnte und das in der liste natürlich immer noch ganz viele andere anbieter stehen etcetera zeigt schon dass man jetzt.
Nicht mehr so ganz einfach die augen zu machen kann und zu tun kann als gäbe es dieses problem nicht im moment ist es,
einfach kein zustand dass man das den schulen beziehungsweise den lehrerinnen und lehrern irgendwie zuschiebt und sagt hier wir können euch keinen klaren empfehlung sagen wir sagen euch nur immer was alles verboten ist oder was nicht geht et cetera aber prüft mal bitte selbst.
Was man ja jetzt im moment tatsächlich datenschutztechnisch macht ich weiß nicht ob du mitgekriegt hat ist die sache mit dem hamburgischen daten beauftragten und skype.
Da gab es abends in den abend meldungen nachrichten dass der hamburgische daten beauftragte skype verboten hätte für die schulen.
Aus meiner ente.
Ja also ich tue mich schwer das als ente zu bezeichnen er hat halt eine pressemitteilung herausgegeben nein so sei das nicht gewesen,
ein mitarbeiter seiner behörde hätte ein gespräch geführt mit der schulbehörde und da hätte man den schulen quasi nahegelegt doch freiwillig darauf zu verzichten so ungefähr.
Also ich bin unsicher was tatsächlich da von wem falsch weitergegeben wurde oder einfach nur zugespitzt weitergegeben wurde
aber selbst dieser zustand
sozusagen zu den schulen zu sagen ihr habt ein problem wir verbieten euch das nicht ihr müsst das selber wissen heißt ja letztlich wir lassen die mit dem problem alleine und wie soll denn eine lehrerin und lehrer entscheiden ob das irgendwie welcher stufe im datenschutz verfahren wo entspricht.
Da würde ich schon sagen braucht's klare ansagen und zwar klare ansagen nicht nur im sinne von verboten ist aber natürlich schwierig für seine datenschutzbeauftragten das sind aufgabe ist ja irgendwie zu warnen und zu sagen geht nicht also fährt braucht es dann nochmal andere instanzen die sagen ja das hier.
Unser list aber im moment stehen da nur die schule eigenen sachen drauf und es ist wirklich häufig kein spaß,
auch da muss man aber sagen kein spaß das heißt ja auch häufig tatsächlich nicht dass das irgendwie so ein bisschen weniger komfort genutzt wird sondern teilweise ist einfach gar nicht genutzt wird also das glaube ich ist häufig sonne,
informatiker oder nerd oder gut betuchte eltern debatte oder sowas siehst sie glauben na ja stellen sie sich doch nicht so an irgendwie dann ist hier model halt hässlich es führt aber halt oft dazu ein solches system das ist einfach
gar nicht genutzt wird und das ist dann ja nicht eine frage von irgendwie ist es ein bisschen schlechter der usability sondern gar nicht nutzung oder ein bisschen nutzung.
Genau das bringt das vielleicht zum letzten oder vorletzten teil nämlich mal so kurz vielleicht mal auch einen überblick zu schaffen.
Was ist eigentlich also was was kommt derzeit zu nutzen oder was kommt überhaupt zur nutzung in frage und zwar jetzt ganz unabhängig von schulspor zischen sachen wie model
nochmal erwähnen können sondern generell also was sind sozusagen jetzt die werkzeuge teilweise haben wir es ja schon benannt was es jetzt quasi im einsatz was scheint sich da zu bewähren was bewährt sich auch.
Nicht und was ja was bleibt dann davon übrig.
Ich trau mich da so wenig irgendwas zu sagen was möglicherweise wenn das jetzt jemand nach ostern hört ähm noch relevant finden könnte weil.
Also jetzt sechster april wir haben in den letzten zehn tagen so glaube ich ungefähr acht mal rauf und runter meldungen zu zoom beispielsweise gehört.
Deswegen würde ich tatsächlich mich mit so ganz konkreten sachen zurückhaltend sondern eher so auf der metaebene sagen irgendwie guckt tatsächlich was euch die länder anbieten nachdem ich da jetzt mal zehn mal drauf geschimpft habe muss man sagen okay das ist immerhin das was.
Da ist sozusagen mit weniger bedenken genutzt werden kann.
Ja gut aber mal so ganz abstrakt ne also videokonferenz ist ja jetzt egal ob irgendwie so um oder in irgendeinem anderen tool wo es mit drin ist oder gitzi oder pipapo das nicht das was ich will sondern sozusagen was braucht,
der schule oder was kann der schulprojekt verwenden was ist was sind sozusagen die art von werkzeugen die,
die sich jetzt sozusagen herausbilden als okay das sollte man sich mal anschauen das zeichnet sich ab dass es auch ein nutzen hat mal ganz unabhängig davon wer das jetzt herstellt welches man benutzt etcetera p.
Also das was glaube ich die situation gerade klar macht ist dass es ganz häufig erstmal um die basics,
arbeitsinspektorat rente geht also das was du oder ich oder jemand irgendwie in dem unternehmen um die ecke jeden tag braucht zum kommunizieren und zum zusammenarbeiten und.
Das hat in der schule seltsamerweise in der it immer irgendwie total niedrige rolle gespielt da hat man sehr viel überredet welche lernclips man braucht,
oder welchen dienst man nimmt irgendwie um um videos abzurufen und videos zu machen etcetera,
diese lern-app etcetera sind ja immer für einen sehr speziellen zweck hilfreich das was man ja jeden tag braucht sind diese ganzen informations-und kommunikations sachen zum austausch zum.
Was du vorhin gesagt hast irgendwie um beispielsweise sachen zu verteilen und wieder einzusammeln um sich abzugleichen miteinander zu sprechen etcetera das glaube ich kriegt jetzt eine größere akzeptanz.
Und auch das ist dann wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr viel anders als wir es dann auch aus der arbeitswelt kennen alle schimpfen auf e-mail aber es ist immer noch die quasi killer application.
Moment tatsächlich auch wieder eher so ein wiederbeleben ist also viele schülerinnen und schüler vermutlich legen sich gerade jetzt irgendwie in corona zeiten nochmal eine neue e-mail-adresse an.
Ja weil es der kleinste gemeinsame nenner ist ne.
Genau ja genau weil es relativ stabil läuft so.
Im gegensatz zu allen anderen was wir da gerade haben,
bei den messenger sachen wird es schon schwieriger also ich vermute nicht dass ich irgendwie da in vielen schulen jetzt slack durchsetzen wird aber tatsächlich schon spannend zu sehen warum teams so viel zuspruch hat also das scheint aber auch auf dieser ebene zu legen dass man da halt irgendwie,
zusammenarbeiten kann ganz basic.
Ja also ich denke dass diese ganzen chat apps also slack hat ja ganz schön was losgetreten und ist ja beileibe nicht das einzige also es gibt
da irgendwie discord was ich im wesentlichen im gamer bereich schon extrem rumgesprochen hatten von daher bei schülern schon extrem gut bekannt ist ja also so discos server und so
candy wasser geht zwar normalerweise um minecraft und fortnite und andere dinger aber die die methodik ist eigentlich allen vollkommen klar und so diese fähigkeit so 'n so 'n so 'n so 'n kollektiven chat rum zu haben wo man jederzeit man kanal aufmachen kann wo man direkt nachrichten schicken kann
wo man geschlossene kanäle haben kann wo man immer was reinpasten kann wo man eine datei hochladen kann etcetera das ist schon so wertvoll ja weil man quasi
so aus dem nichts heraus ein klassenraum schaffen kann wo alle schüler drin sein können ist es klar,
jeder hat die möglichkeit selber einzustellen auf welchem device dass betritt auf welche art und weise um welche uhrzeit davon notifiziert wird oder nicht notifiziert wird man kann gleichzeitig quasi das.
Das geheime klassenmangel sprich mit seinem
sitz nach bonn führen aber eben gewisser hinsicht auch dem unterricht folgen man kann jederzeit eine frage öffentlich stellen man kann was nachfragen automatisch und moment also das ist zum beispiel etwas was ich nicht verstehe warum warum das nicht sehr schnell
einzug hält also ich denke denke solche träume sind einfach geil zumal sie eben auch noch einen anderen effekt haben was wir eingangs auch schon gesagt haben es ist halt auch ohne dass man jetzt permanent diese kamera aufmerksamkeit haben muss
so ein lagerfeuer was einfach die ganze zeit sowohl leise vor sich hin knistert man weiß einfach aha hier schule findet statt ja
ich kann das im prinzip auch,
rund vierundzwanzig stunden nutzen ich weiß die ganze klasse ist da ich kann da beliebig viele gruppen anlegen und es gibt aber dann vielleicht eben tada.
Um zehn uhr ist dann halt auch mal eine stunde lang schule,
so und dann wissen alle okay jetzt ist auch mal mit videokonferenz und die klassenlehrerin klassen der klassenlehrer.
Da ruft dann alle auf wird euch auch mal ein und mach mal kameraden und so weiter wenn es euch möglich ist oder,
muss ja auch nicht sein dass jetzt jeder auch noch seine eigene fresse dahin schicksal dass man sich einfach nur den stream anschaut und.
Sieht so a hier personen spricht zu mir so aufmerksamkeit jetzt schule a wichtig hier
tralala dinge im kontext setzen alle mal begrüßen alle mal hallo gesagt haben sich mal bedanken auch mal verständnis dafür zeigen dass die zeiten schwierig sind et cetera ja und dass er das auch alle gut gemacht haben die köpfe ein bisschen stralsund all diese ganzen elemente und dann
hast du quasi nur zwei werkzeuge war schon relativ viel abgefangen.
Genau du hast auch das halt so einen ausgangs von so einem basecamp oder lagerfeuer hast du schon gesagt ne
so hier das ist unser ausgangspunkt hier treffen wir uns immer hier kommen wir auch wieder zurück hier gehe ich hin wenn ich desorientiert bin etcetera und von da aus kann ich da eine unterschiedliche richtung los und
der lehrer kann sagen hier irgendwie probiert mal diese app aus oder die lehrerin kann sagen hier ich habe euch ein video gemacht und bei youtube hochgeladen
oder die lehrerin kann sagen jemand anderes hat ein video gemacht und bei youtube hochgeladen guckt euch das mal an,
und dann ist auch egal selbst wenn morgen youtube zusammenfällt kann das video möglicherweise noch woanders sehen aber dieses basislager.
Vielleicht ist das der effekt den den teams an vielen orten hat.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen und das dass es dafür eine stärke akzeptanz gibt das kann ich mir vorstellen dass es nach einer corinna krise in einem eventuell gedacht normalzustand dann wieder sein könnte,
dieses basislager im virtuellen raum auch relevanz haben also hat es ja jetzt schon jetzt irgendwie war es halt häufig selbst wenn lehrer gar nichts gemacht hat dann hätten sie dann immer noch eine whatsapp-gruppe unter den schülern.
Also man kann das sozusagen auch nicht irgendwie sagen doch ich kann sagen ich verweigere mich dem komplett aber dann schaffen sich die lernenden quasi ihre eigene infrastruktur das ist das was ja manchen lehrerinnen und lehrern auch immer noch nicht klar war
sozusagen nicht mehr die hoheit haben sondern sie haben nur die wahl irgendwie eine whatsapp-gruppe mit ihnen oder ohne sie.
Genau.
Die haben eh halt die die die mächtigere infrastruktur irgendwie selbst.
Diese idee dass man sozusagen das als autoritäre institution die schule ja nun ist es ja auch so gedacht gesellschaftlich,
dass die dann irgendwie immer das sagen hätte funktioniert da nicht mehr,
und da kann man schon viel lernen von dem was andere gelernt haben ich weiß nicht ob du dich erinnerst es war doch es gab schon zehn jahre her das ist bei einem autohersteller in wolfsburg diese vereinbarung gehabt dass abends die e-mails nicht mehr zugestellt werden.
Und,
das hat dazu geführt dass die leute die abends dann weiter arbeiten mussten sich die geheimen irgendwie keine ahnung konstruktionspläne irgendwie über web de geschickt haben oder so,
weil sie nicht darauf angewiesen waren dass irgendwie der laden da irgendwie ihren e-mail-server weiter abends betreibt,
und ob das jetzt im interesse von vw war dass die da ihre konstruktionspläne über web de verschickt haben weil sie auch nicht.
Ah
aber jetzt gibt's ja noch einen anderen problemfall nämlich so dieses was wir auch schon erwähnt hast was ich als herausforderung auch zeigt nämlich dieses hausaufgaben einsammeln.
Das ist natürlich etwas was man jetzt mit so einem chat naja auch nicht unbedingt so sehr viel einfacher machen kann weil da braucht man ja eigentlich
eher so ein automatisiertes system wo man sagt so hier sind die hausaufgaben hier sind die leute die das alles erhalten sollen ich stelle dir da ein dann gehen die raus dann kriegt jeder per
was auch immer ja also wenn man es mit so 'nem chat system verbinden könnte wäre es ja wunderbar dass es da halt gleich
aufpoppt und das system vielleicht auch gleich weiß was das ist da weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht microsoft teams da irgendwas entsprechendes im angebot hat oder ob man es war einfach nur dafür benutzt,
aber so ein system was dann eben auch die deadlines kennt und sagt so bis dann und dann und vielleicht auch sagen wir mal wenn's.
Sechs stunden vorher noch nicht da ist nochmal eine meer rausschickt und sagt so ne wie ist es denn.
Kannst du wahrscheinlich also glaube ich sogar in teams abbilden stück weit.
Das ist so ein bisschen die frage also beispielsweise dieses irgendwie kontrolle und so weiter also ich finde im moment tatsächlich sagen irgendwie das schwierigste ist irgendwie wie du feedback abbilden kannst weil das irgendwo hinzuschicken und kontrollieren das angekommen ist das eine,
wenn du als schülerinnen oder schüler irgendwie aber merkst es relativ egal ob du's hingeschickt hast oder nicht es kommt nicht zurück.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich folgenreiche ich sehe im moment ganz spannende sachen dass da viele lehrerinnen und lehrer mit mit verschiedenen improvisierten system von sprachnachrichten experimentieren im rückmeldungen zu geben.
Weil es natürlich anstrengend ist jedem schüler keine ahnung nochmal einzeln ins gespräch zu geben mit dreißig schülern am tag oder sowas.
Aber wenn du was von denen durch liegst und irgendwie dir sozusagen den dann eine sprachnachricht schickst,
mit feedback et cetera das ist im moment vielleicht nicht,
technologisch dass irgendwie größte was wir uns vorstellen können aber ich glaube es funktioniert ganz gut weil du halbwegs individuell drauf eingehen kannst irgendwie was du da vor dir siehst dann aufgaben weil auch konkrete sachen sagen kannst,
und weil es viel stärker irgendwie auch nochmal die persönliche ebene unterstützt als wenn du eine app hast die einfach nur acht mal rot map sagst wenn du irgendwas falsch angekreuzt hast.
Da bin ich gespannt was da weitergeht aber da gibt es bildet sich im moment aus meiner sicht nicht irgendwie ein standard raus weil ja auch die plattform wenn sie schon welche haben dann eigene sachen haben keine ahnung bei model hast du da auch deine eigenen aufgaben funktionen etcetera da gibt es aus meiner sicht nichts,
übergreifendes was da gerade passiert.
Aber es gibt schon software die die das abbildet.
Ja also model teams haben wir gesagt irgendwie die haben da jeweils irgendwie so eigene sachen wo du irgendwie aufgaben verteilen und deadline setzen kannst und so weiter punkt.
Okay ja vielleicht so zum abschluss nochmal so ein bisschen auf die metaebene klettern was ist denn so dein gefühl was.
Was jetzt so bleiben müsste eigentlich von dieser zeit nicht was wird sondern was müsste.
Was müsste es tatsächlich ich komme ja immer schon fast ein bisschen esoterisch vor aber so,
wie sehr wir jetzt gerade sehen was wirklich wichtig ist also es ist schon wichtig dass wir alle mathe lernen dafür haben wir auch das irgendwie erfunden mit der schule.
Aber wie sehr,
es wichtig ist da irgendwie so 'ne grundlage zu haben und die schülerinnen und schüler zu sehen dass es den halbwegs gut geht nicht im sinne von irgendwie dass die wellness haben und für die betüteln müssen oder sowas aber beispielsweise zu sehen
sie haben zu hause keinen platz wo sie in ruhe hausaufgaben machen können.
Das können wir vielleicht doof finden aber es ist so bei vielen schülerinnen und schüler und das wird jetzt gerade nochmal deutlich sichtbarer bisher war das für natürlich wussten lehrer und lehrerinnen das aber irgendwie hat sich die gesellschaft damit abgefunden dass das bei vielen so ist,
und dass die lehrer da auch nicht viel machen können und dass sozusagen diese sachen die wir im alltag häufig als selbstverständlich angenommen haben gerade durch diesen zustand plötzlich,
anders zu sehen sind wenn davon viel bleibt über so ein geschärft deren blick haben das ist dann ja noch nicht eine revolution die dadurch entsteht aber.
Viele sachen sehen okay das könnte auch anders sein und es hilft nicht wenn ich irgendwie einfach die strafen für hausaufgaben zu spät abgegeben verdreifache das löst das problem möglicherweise nicht von den kindern die die nicht machen.
Fände ich schon viel.
Also was mir auch noch mal so ein
das ist tatsächlich jetzt schon vor ausbruch der krise so ein problem gewesen und jetzt finde ich das irgendwie auch nochmal krasser jetzt haben die hausaufgaben alles kommt sowieso das internet ansonsten dinge recherchieren sonst irgendwas zu irgendwas schreiben.
Und dann hatte ich dann so mit meinen kindern die situation fragt so ja wie ist denn das sind ist nicht so ja.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so genau weil das doch mal einer wikipedia nachschlagen so dann kam so ja nee wikipedia dürfen wir nicht benutzen was.
Wie wikipedia darfst du nicht wieso das nicht so ja weil da kann ja jeder was reinschreiben dass sie auch noch so was.
Zweitausendzwanzig.
Ja genau so was ist jetzt los hat irgendwie das jahr zwanzig zehn wieder angerufen und seine bedenken geäußert.
Was das ja sozusagen sagt ist das einfach dieses wissen um die netz realitäten einfach,
an der stelle dann noch nicht richtig angekommen sind also wenn du das vielleicht das argument nicht nachvollziehen kann so ja klar kann ja jeder was reinschreiben aber der glaube dass halt auf all den webseiten wo nur einer was reinschreiben kann das automatisch die wahrheit ist
das ist halt auch fern der realität.
Es ist schon wieder dieser effekt von irgendwie sichtbar machen oder nicht sichtbar sein also wenn wir im moment halt irgendwie viel stärker noch sehen.
Was teilweise sonst im unterricht passiert also es ist ja nicht so dass das sozusagen irgendwie jetzt.
Plötzlich auch die tollsten lehrer dann irgendwie hilflos dastehen sondern manche lehrer stehen vielleicht auch im alltag hilflos da man sieht es halt nur nicht weil es hinter verschlossenen türen geschieht und die schülerinnen und schüler nur bestimmte sachen mit nach hause bringen oder sowas.
Das kann natürlich auch so ein effekt von der korona situation sein dass wir irgendwie viel mehr sehen was wir im alltag auch nicht sehen wollten.
Vielleicht gibt's viele überforderte lehrerinnen und lehrer.
Bestimmt den muss auch geholfen werden johann ich sage an dieser stelle erstmal vielen dank für die ausführung.
Wir begleiten das mal und
gucken ob wie jetzt das überhaupt erstmal weitergeht du wirst mir ja zu diesem zeitpunkt alle noch nicht ob die schulen wirklich wieder aufmachen können und dann dann wird's natürlich auch interessant weil dann wird es natürlich auch aus den schulen heraus ein ganz anderes feedback
geben ich denke es ist auf jeden fall auch für eltern und auch für schüler,
an dieser stelle ganz sinnvoll mal über all die ganzen auswirkungen nachzudenken dass wir danach eine etwas fruchtbare diskussion führen können.
So und ich sag vielen dank fürs zuhören bei ukw wie man bald geht's weiter und in diesen zeiten relativ schnell.